für die aussprache ist eine dauer- und
wir sind wieder live im bundestag hier
wird jetzt nämlich über den bundeswehr
einsatz im irak gesprochen wir sehen
hier schon bundes außenministerin
annalena baerbock die hier die debatte
mit ihrer rede eröffnet wird
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen die zustimmung des bundestages
zu auslandseinsätzen der bundeswehr ist
nie eine selbstverständlichkeit es ist
als hohes gut aus der deutschen
geschichte erwachsen dass wir in
deutschland eine parlamentsarmee haben
und das ist uns allen immer wieder
bewusst das gilt auch für das mandat zur
teilnahme der bundeswehr am
internationalen militäreinsatz gegen den
sogenannten islamischen staates und zur
stabilisierung des iraks
ausgangspunkt dieses einsatzes war das
furchtbare wütender us terror
organisation in irak und syrien ab
sommer 2014 ihr es terroristen eroberten
damals ganze landstriche große städte
wie san joe oder moz dort terrorisierten
sie die zivilbevölkerung ganz besonders
die gruppe der sieben männer und selbst
minderjährige jungen wurden erschossen
frauen verschleppt viele versklavt und
vergewaltigt einige von ihnen immer noch
wieder nicht zurück und kinder als
sklaven oder
sklaven oder kindersoldaten missbraucht
das unterstreicht wie wichtig der kampf
gegen den islamischen staat für die
internationale sicherheit ist und so wie
es der vn sicherheitsrat in seiner
resolution deutlich gemacht hat ist er
es auch für die menschen im irak selbst
und für die stabilität in der region
gleichzeitig ist es kein geheimnis
dass meine fraktion und ich auch selbst
persönlich dem anti es mandat des
bundestages 2015 und in den jahren
danach nicht zugestimmt haben grund
dafür war nicht unsere ablehnung der
ziele des einsatzes sondern unsere
bedenken zu seiner damaligen rechtlichen
basis
die neue bundesregierung hat das mandat
nun überarbeitet und ich danke vor allen
dingen der verteidigungsministerin
christine lambrecht sehr für die
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit dabei und
ich werbe sehr verehrte damen und herren
für ihre zustimmung zu diesem nun
deutlich überarbeiteten mandat
denn erstens
denn erstens wird der einsatz jetzt auf
den irak fokussiert syrien als
einsatzgebiet haben wir gestrichen und
das ist eine deutliche änderung
mit dem erneuten wunsch mit dem erneuten
und deutlichen wunsch der irakischen
regierung nach einer fortsetzung des
einsatzes der bundeswehr steht der neue
mandatstext auf einer klaren
völkerrechtlichen grundlagen und daneben
ist der bundeswehr einsatz von den
einschlägigen resolutionen des un
sicherheitsrates und artikel 51 der
charta gedeckt
zweitens sieht dieses mandat und ja das
ist neu eine umfassende und inklusive
evaluation des einsatzes in den
kommenden mandats zeitraum vor und damit
setzen wir erstmalig die vereinbarung
unseres koalitionsvertrages um alle
bundeswehr auslandseinsätze zu
evaluieren
wir verlängern
wir verlängern das mandat bis zum 31
oktober 2022 und kehren damit zum
ursprünglichen turnus einer
mandatsverlängerung im herbst zurück und
drittens und das ist wichtig braucht der
irak weiterhin unseren zivilen und
militärischen
beistand wir sehen dort einerseits nicht
zu lang nicht zuletzt auch dank
internationaler unterstützung positive
entwicklung die waren im vergangen
oktober waren die sichersten und
freiesten in der geschichte des landes
und die fortschritte der irakischen
sicherheitskräfte haben es erlaubt die
internationale militärpräsenz
weiterzuentwickeln
die mission der internationalen anti es
koalition und die amerikanische militär
einsätze werden von einem kampfeinsatz
zu einer beratungs und
unterstützungsmission umgebaut
andererseits und das sage ich auch sehr
deutlich ist klar trotz dieser erfolge
steht der irak weiter vor großen
herausforderungen
das haben die tragischen anschläge der
vergangenen nacht in bagdad noch einmal
unterstrichen einige akteure versuchen
die regierungsbildung zum entgleisen zu
bringen mit raketenangriffen auf
diplomatische verträgen vertretung und
anschläge auf parteibüros und auch wenn
ihr es seid 2017 kein gelände mehr in
irak beherrscht bleibt er eine gefahr
wurde irakische staat oder die autonome
region kurdistan seine sicherheits
verantwortung nicht wahrnimmt handeln
terroristen aus dem untergrund und sind
zu komplexeren anschlägen in der lage
dieser terroristischen bedrohung müssen
wir weiter entgegen treten dreh und
angelpunkt ist dabei unser vernetzte
ansatz
unser
unser bundeswehreinsatz bleibt
eingebettet in ein starkes ziviles
engagement seit 2013 hat deutschland in
irak fast drei milliarden euro für
humanitäre hilfe
stabilisierung und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit investiert
meine damen meine herren um dieses
zivile engagement abzusichern braucht es
weiterhin auch militärische mittel und
deshalb wäre die verlängerung des
vorliegenden mandates ein wichtiges
signal an unsere partnerinnen und
partner in ihrer an unsere alliierten
freunde dass deutschland auch unter der
neuen bundesregierung ein verlässlicher
bündnispartner bleibt und vor allen
dingen an die kinder an die männer und
an die frauen die nach 2014 in ihrer so
fürchterlich unter der terrorherrschaft
des gelitten haben ich bitte um ihre
unterstützung herzlichen dank
aussenministerin und alina der burg wird
so für die verlängerung des irak
einsatzes noch ende oktober 2020 hatten
die grünen dagegen gestimmt allerdings
ist nun das einsatzgebiet syrien
ausgeschlossen und so hofft man auch
noch mit einer evaluierungs klausel hier
auf die zustimmung der eigenen fraktion
jürgen hardt spreche für auswärtig ist
der unionsfraktion und
kollegen das ist das erste mandat was
die neue bundesregierung den deutschen
bundestag zur beratung vorliegt deswegen
möchte ich vorab für meine fraktion für
die cdu/csu-fraktion sagen sie dürfen
sich darauf verlassen dass wir zu diesen
wichtigen entscheidungen die ja auch für
die soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz
von besonderer wichtigkeit sind für die
menschen in den einsatzgebieten dass wir
unsere konstruktiv kritisch wohlwollende
haltung bewahren und dass wir nicht in
opposition zu diesen anträgen verfallen
und ich möchte an dieser stelle schon
ein wenig süffisant anmerken dass
vermutlich und auch meine kollegen in
der cdu csu fraktion ihr
abstimmungsverhalten zu dem irak mandat
für die bundeswehr
diesmal auch nicht ändern müssen anders
als die bundesministerin das
herauspicken
ich möchte zu dem irak mandat folgende
grundlegende anmerkungen machen
eine der bindenden klammern der
allermeisten einsätze der bundeswehr
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr ist der
kampf gegen den internationalen
terrorismus weil wir wissen dass die
globale lage ist eben nicht zulässt dass
wir uns vor solchen entwicklungen
wegducken sondern dass wir sie beherzt
angehen müssen weil sonst der
terrorismus früher oder später auch uns
unmittelbar bedroht und ministerin
lamprecht war im irak und hat es im
grunde auch so formuliert und ich möchte
an dieser stelle sagen die sicherheit
deutschlands wird eben auch an euphrat
und tigris verteidigt mit den geeigneten
mitteln die wir dafür haben deswegen ist
es gut dass wir die irakische regierung
weiter auf ihren wunsch hin mit
ausbildungen unterstützen ist es gut
dass wir in der allianz gegen den gegen
den
svk das zusammenstehen und es ist im
übrigen auch gut und wenn ich das an
dieser stelle an die kollegen der spd
sagen darf wir hatten am anfang als wir
diesen einsatz begonnen haben probleme
damit in der großen koalition zu
vereinbaren dass auch der nato-einsatz
dass deutsche kräfte auch im rahmen des
nato-einsatzes eingesetzt werden dürfen
das haben wir gott sei dank überwinden
können und es ist auch gut dass in dem
jetzigen mandatstext dieser bezug auf
die nato mission in iraq eben auch da
ist dass sich als positives zeichen wenn
ich den mandatstext dem er erst seid ja
man kann fast sagen wenigen stunden
vorliegt das ist ja im ersten dieser
woche zu diesem text gekommen stelle ich
schon fest dass er doch sehr weitgehend
mit dem übereinstimmt was wir bisher
haben sie haben in der überschrift
syrien gestrichen das ist natürlich
ein mehr symbolisch zu verstehen weil
auch seit frühjahr 2020 wie auch keine
luftaufklärung deutsche tornados mehr
über syrien haben also de facto ist
dieser einsatz tatsächlich nicht hatte
der einsatz tatsächlich nicht syrisches
starts begriff umfasst ich finde das ist
allerdings ein makel ich finde diese
künstliche begrenzung nur auf den irak
birgt eine in gefahr in sich diebe
andererseits ja auch in den mandats
testen wir betonen nämlich dass de es
grenzüberschreitend und regionen
überschreiten bearbeitet und dass wir
die gefahr schon sehen dass durch die
situation im nordosten des iraks
nordosten syriens eine gefahr besteht
dass dieser die es terrorismus den wir
im irak gemeinsam erfolgreich massiv
zurückgedrängt wendigkeit vertrieben
haben dass er im nordosten syriens ohne
dass wir hunde dass wir dahin schauen
würden eine entsprechende wieder
erstarrung erfährt und dass er eines
tages zurück fluten könnte nach irak je
nachdem wie sich die dinge entwickeln
deswegen halten wir diese
diese künstliche begrenzung
haben wir sie ihm bereits im alten
mandat und halten sie auch im neuen
mandat für künstlich und falsch und
deswegen plädieren wir dafür einen
grösseren umfassenderen mutigeren ansatz
zu fassen im nordosten des syriens gibt
es keine
politische herrschaft außer die der dass
das des und deswegen ist es legitim sich
gegen eine solche bedrohung auch an der
seite iraks zu werden ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir die luftaufklärung
wieder aufnehmen
übrigens ist es ja so dass nachdem wir
dort unsere ein flüge von ahlers tag
eingestellt haben nicht so ohne weiteres
andere partner diese aufgabe übernommen
haben weil nämlich die deutschen
fähigkeiten die es zu tun doch ein stück
weit eine kern und schlüssel fähigkeit
innerhalb der nato sind und deswegen
nicht so ohne weiteres unverzichtbar
genauso wie im übrigen laufen sie eine
zwischenfrage der kollegin stark zu
machen frau kollegin statt über mutter
dass sie mir erlauben eine zwischenfrage
zu stellen sie sagten gerade dass sie
das mandat dahingehend verändern wollen
würden sie hier doch nochmal erklären
das ist die cdu csu war die dass die das
initiiert hat dass die tornados
abgezogen wurden sind aus jordanien mit
der maßgabe dass am ersten april 2020
die italiener dieses mandat übernehmen
das nie passiert ist deswegen überrascht
mich doch jetzt ihre einlassung dass sie
das ganz anders machen würden
ich glaube ich glaube dass dieses
kollegen der sozialdemokratie mit
zustimmt werden dass wir damals hart um
dieses mandat gerungen haben und auch um
diese veränderung dass es in meiner
fraktion wir keine notwendigkeit saßen
diese änderung vorzunehmen weil wir eben
die sorge hatten dass es eben dann zu
einem wegfall dieser fähigkeit kommt und
ich komme bis zum heutigen tage und auch
im blick auf das neue mandat zum schluss
dass es besser wäre wenn die deutsche
bundeswehr diese fähigkeit der allianz
gegen tesch zur verfügung stellen würde
und auch luftaufklärung in diesem
bereich übrigens durchführen würde das
ist leider in der großen koalition so
nicht möglich gewesen es ist
offensichtlich in diesen mandatstext
auch nicht möglich aber wenn ich ihn zu
schreiben hätte würde ich es beim
schalten
möchte die letzten sekunden
nutzen um deutlich zu machen dass wir
jetzt ein toughes programm vor uns haben
wir werden in der nächsten sitzungswoche
in den ausschüssen das mandat beraten
müssen und es wird dann bereits in der
nächsten sitzungswoche auch
verabschiedet werden müssen weil wir
sonst den 31 januar verpassen ich
erinnere mich daran dass wir einen
ziemlich harten kampf mit unseren
sozialdemokratischen kollegen hatten ob
wir das mandat tatsächlich bis zum 31
januar laufen lassen spd wollte das
etwas früher beenden ich bin froh dass
es gelungen ist es bis dahin auszudehnen
dass wir jetzt immerhin doch die fristen
waren können ich sage eine konstruktive
mit mit beratung der seitens der cdu csu
zu und eine gute debatte in der nächsten
woche dankeschön
für auswärtige politik jürgen hardt und
christine lambrecht hat hier heute schon
einmal gesprochen die
bundesverteidigungsministerium
anlässlich der debatte zur politik des
bundes zur verteidigung aber jetzt wird
sie sich hier auch nochmal zum
bundeswehr einsetzen
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die deutsche bundeswehr ist
eine parlamentsarmee und deswegen ist es
auch richtig und wichtig dass wir diese
mandate jedes mal hier auch ausführlich
und intensiv diskutieren und das heute
ist jetzt der einstieg in dieses so
genannte irak mandat und es ist wichtig
es ist wichtig dass alle fragen hier
auch im parlament diskutiert werden das
ist mir ein großes anliegen ich war 23
jahre
bundestagsabgeordnete und deswegen kann
ich das auch richtig gut nachvollziehen
dass das eingefordert wird und dann will
ich dann aber auch
aber damit ich dann als
verteidigungsministerin auch die
entsprechenden antworten die
entsprechenden eindrücke über die
aktuelle lage geben kann deswegen habe
ich am letzten wochenende eine einsatz
reise gehabt nach jordanien in den irak
und auch in die autonome region
kurdistan nach erbil mir war es wichtig
mir vor ort ein bild darüber zu machen
was leisten denn unsere soldatinnen
soldaten was machen die denn ganz
konkret in manchmal habe ich den
eindruck ist es gar nicht bekannt was
wirklich geleistet wird was wirklich
unsere aufgabe dort vor ort ist und wie
kommt es auch dort in der region an in
jordanien im irak den kurdistan und ich
kann ihnen sagen alle diese gespräche
haben 1 ergeben unsere frauen und männer
dort leisten eine tolle arbeit hoch
anerkannt und hoch erwünscht und in
allen gesprächen wurde deutlich unsere
taten und partner unserer verbündeten
bauen auf uns und unsere truppe
überzeugt eben über durch ihr engagement
und ihr können und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir jetzt auch diese
verlängerung hier beschließen zu der
evaluierung komme ich gleich aber es ist
eben wichtig weil die frau kollegin
außenminister bin schon gesagt hat der
es ist noch lange nicht besiegt er ist
zurück getrennt es konnten gute
entwicklung gute gutes erreicht werden
dabei ist noch lange nicht besiegt er
herrscht zwar nicht mehr über große
teile gebiete im irak und in syrien auch
durch unser engagement der
bundesregierung aber der es ist immer
noch da und er sorgt mit seinen willen
mit seinen mitteln mit seinen
möglichkeiten vor ort in der region für
terror und deswegen es ist richtig dass
wir uns dagegen weiterhin einbringen
denn die für die menschen im iran
mit dem da ist die angst die angst vor
diesem terror die ist allgegenwärtig sie
wissen ganz genau dass denke es
jederzeit wieder zuschlagen kann auf
einem belebten markt oder auch auf einem
kontrollpunkt der polizei egal wo und
die sagt terror ist es schon
angesprochen worden der reicht eben auch
bis nach europa wir sind davor nicht
sicher das ist keine auf die region
begrenzte gefahr sondern das betrifft
uns auch und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass auch wahrzunehmen deswegen ist es
nicht nur im interesse des iraks nicht
nur im interesse von vier tage nicht nur
in der in trenton interesse der region
wenn wir uns dort engagiert sondern auch
in unserem interesse
und unsere unsere militärische
unterstützung die werden wir dabei auf
zwei säulen aufbauen einmal mit der nato
mission im irak stärken wir die
irakischen streitkräfte
dass sie dann irgendwann selbst in der
lage sind auch operative einsätze
vollständig voller
eigenständig durchführen zukommt aber
wir kämpfen und beraten eben auch im
kampf gegen denise und die regierung die
irakische regierung ich habe ja mit den
händen mir gesprochen hat ausdrücklich
und wiederholt den wunsch geäußert dass
wir unser engagement
fortsetzen ich habe auch mit dem mitmach
irakischen amtskollegen gesprochen und
überall dort die ausdrückliche bitte und
was machen wir dort allein durch unser
hochmodernes tankflugzeug a400m das hat
in den vergangenen 15 monaten über 200
betankungsflugzeuge führt und dadurch
insbesondere unsere französische unsere
französischen 1
also so wird das sind in diesem einen
jahr in diesen 15 monaten nicht aber wir
können die zahl sicherlich miteinander
erklären aber ich bin mir sicher wenn
mir eine ganz tolle
aufgestellten kolleginnen und kollegen
aus dem ministerium solle zahl da rein
schreiben dann stimmt die auch wir haben
solche
auf jeden fall egal welche die zahl
jetzt auch lautet auf jeden fall haben
wir einen unglaublichen beitrag dazu
geleistet dass eben wie gesagt die
französischen kollegen und auch die usa
dadurch direkt unterstützt werden
konnten aber nicht nur das wissen guter
beitrag sondern auch dadurch dass
beispielsweise unsere sanitäterinnen und
sanitäter in erbil internationale
internationale struktur fest integriert
sind das ist ein ganz wichtiger baustein
so waren es nämlich die kameradinnen und
kameraden aller koalitions nationen die
dort angegriffen wurden durch einen
drohnenangriff und unsere sanitäterinnen
und sanitäter haben diese dann im camp
versorgen können ein ganz wichtiger
beitrag den wir da leisten sie haben
viel erreicht die kolleginnen und
kollegen
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir da
auch weiterhin unterstützend tätig sein
und ja dieses mandat ist jetzt verändert
es ist eben kein weiter so es ist eben
nicht wir machen jetzt einfach im jahr
weiter mit dem was wir bisher geleistet
haben es ist schon beschrieben worden
das einsatzgebiet ist eingeschränkt
worden dass syrien ist jetzt nicht mehr
enthalten und es hat damit etwas zu tun
dass wir eben auch seit
2020 dort überhaupt nicht mehr aktiv
waren und dann finde ich gehört es auch
zur transparenz zur ehrlichkeit dazu
dass man das eben auch klar benennt und
das ist jetzt mit diesem mandat der fall
und ja wir verlängern jetzt bis ende
oktober dieses jahres damit kommen wir
wieder in den vorher vorherigen rhythmus
zurück und nach das gibt uns jetzt
zeitgenau noch mal zu hinterfragen ob
das was wir da leisten in die richtige
richtung geht oder auch wir besser noch
besser werden können wir mussten
beispielsweise ausbildungsmission
zurückfahren corona bedingt und es ist
eine frage ob wir da nicht wieder rein
gehen ins engagement auch das muss in so
einer zeit die wir jetzt zur verfügung
haben diskutiert werden und wir haben
uns die zeit und ich finde wir sollten
jetzt auch uns die zeit nehmen deswegen
an dieser stelle ganz klar das
engagement wird hoch geschätzt es wird
darum gebeten dass wir weitermachen dass
wir weitermachen um die region zu
stabilisieren und aber auch zu helfen
dass der irak irgendwann eigenständig
diese leistungen erbringen kann und
deswegen bitte ich sie um unterstützung
dieses hoch anerkannten engagement dort
vor ort in der region für die region
aber eben auch für unsere sicherheit
vielen dank
die
bundesverteidigungsministerium wirbt für
die verlängerung des einsatzes im irak
bis zum 31 oktober soll er verlängert
werden bis zu 500 deutsche soldatinnen
und soldaten sollen eingesetzt werden
joachim wundrak fdp fraktion spricht
jetzt zum ersten mal
dass die rede zu ende geht ich kann dann
noch mal gegen das mikro klopfen kurz
vorher dass sie dann auch bescheid
wissen bitteschön
frau präsidentin ich danke für das wort
und für die freundliche
einführung von minister in bernburg frau
ministerin lamprecht meine damen und
herren wir alle in diesem haus stimmen
wohl zu dass entscheidungen zum einsatz
von bewaffneten streitkräfte
der besonderen sorgfalt bedürfen dies
nicht nur zum schutz der eingesetzten
soldaten sondern auch um verfassung und
völkerrecht nicht zu verletzen
wie schon gehört übernahm 2014 der ers
die kontrolle über große gebiete irak
und syrien deutschland unterstützt seit
anfang
2015 den kampf gegen den erst durch
ausbildung und ausrüstung von irakischen
streitkräfte
nach den terror-anschlägen in paris im
november 2015 entschied sich deutschland
die internationale allianz gegen den es
auch durch den einsatz mit
militärflugzeugen zu unterstützen
wie noch einige hier im haus erinnere
ich die heißen diskussionen um die
völkerrechtliche bewertung der
kampfflugzeuge über syrien natürlich
ohne einladung der syrischen regierung
eingesetzt wurden die fdp fraktion hat
vorausgegangene anträge daher aus
völkerrechtlichen bedenken abgelehnt
aber auch die fraktionen der grünen wir
haben das schon gehört stimmte gegen
diese einsätze und gegen in ihrer kritik
sogar noch deutlich weiter ihr heutiger
staatssekretär frau ministerin berbalk
bezeichnete das vorige mandat als
rechtswidrig ich weiß nicht ob auch er
vom völkerrecht kommt aber er
kritisierte dass man aus der resolution
der vereinten nationen nicht klar und
ein deutlich herauslesen könne dass ein
gewalteinsatz in syrien gerechtfertigt
sei
der einsatz entspreche auch nicht den
vorgaben des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
und ist in der tat der einzige
auslandseinsatz der bundeswehr in einer
koalition der nicht im rahmen der eu
nato oder vereinten nationen stattfindet
und der islamische staat kontrolliert
anders als in 2015 inzwischen keine
gebiete mehr im irak und in syrien die
verletzungen des syrischen luftraums ist
heute daher noch schwerer zu
rechtfertigen
als damals die ministerinnen bitten in
ihrem antrag heute dennoch um zustimmung
dass die bundeswehr
lufteinsätze anderer staaten über syrien
auch weiterhin unterstützen kann
dies soll laut ihrem antrag durch
luftbetankung
luftraumüberwachung aufklärung und
weitergabe gewonnener informationen
geschehe
der unmut der sich hierüber in ihrer
fraktion und in der spd regt ist
nachvollziehbar
dagegen ist der auftrag zur ausbildung
irakischer streitkräfte ebenfalls in
ihrem antrag enthalten
prinzipiell sinnvoll und
zustimmungsfähig wir begrüßen auch die
absicht der von uns wiederholt
geforderten fortlaufenden evaluierung
der einsätze
sie sollten diese beiden völkerrechtlich
völlig unterschiedlich begründeten
einsätze auf der einen seite ausbildung
auf der anderen seite kampf gegen den us
mit bewaffneten mitteln nicht in einem
antrag und zu einem mandat verknüpfen
sie sollten dem parlament die
möglichkeit geben über zwei getrennte
mandate zu beraten wie es auch die fdp 1
eingefordert hat dies wurde auf vielen
parlamentariern in ihrer fraktion und
der spd eine brücke bauen eine spd die
wohl heute schon den ausstieg aus dem
mandat in neun monaten
planen
um es kurz zu machen die fdp fraktion
kann ihrem antrag in dieser form nicht
zustimmen ich bitte oder ich bedanke
mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
für ihre art gepackt wird den antrag
ablehnen
die handlung drug an nach dieser rede
wird der antrag allerdings erst einmal
federführend an den auswärtigen
ausschuss überwiesen und dann dort
nochmal diskutiert und kommt dann erst
wieder ins plenum zur abstimmung
alexander müller spricht jetzt für die
fdp-fraktion
kollegen der islamische staat ist weiter
aktiv und betreibt betreibt seine
hinterhältigen anschläge dazu betreibt
ein internationales netzwerk mit wirkung
bis nach afghanistan und nach afrika und
ist der haupttreiber von einer
fluchtwelle nach europa und zum thema
syrien lieber kollege hart ich verstehe
ihre schmerzen wir wissen ja dass die
damaligen verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer öffentlich darüber
nachgedacht und es wäre soldaten im
norden syriens einzusetzen wir wollen
das aber nicht und deswegen ist auch
konsequent das gebiet syriens da raus zu
nehmen
der irakische nachbar iran wird
zusätzlich die stabilisierende in der
region unterstützt dort überall krieg
und terror ob es der islamische dschihad
ist die houthi rebellen im jemen die
hisbollah werden allesamt vom iran
beliefert und unterstützt und wenn es
der frisch gewählten irakischen
regierung die übrigens eine multi
ethnische unten inklusive regierung ist
wenn es den gelingt die demokratie zu
stabilisieren dann ist es ein
fortschritt für frieden im arabischen
raum und das ist das ziel mit diesem
mandat irak ist ein vielvölkerstaat ist
keine klassische nation sondern besteht
aus arabern und kurden aus sunniten
schiiten christen jesiden und das
zusammenwachsen als nation das bilden
einer gemeinschaft also ein nation
building ist dort noch lange nicht
fertig wir haben ein großes interesse am
erfolg dieses prozesses am erfolg eines
stabilen und friedlichen irak die usa
haben seit kurzem keine truppen mit
kampfaufgaben land und auch das ist ein
wichtiges zeichen des fortschritts und
der stabilisierung die bundeswehr ist
auch bitten der irakischen regierung vor
ort ihm verbunden mit vielen anderen
truppen herrscht truppenstellern aus der
ganzen welt damit erfüllen wir auch die
anforderungen des un-sicherheitsrats zur
mitarbeit an der eindämmung des
dozenten keine kampftruppen sondern wir
unterstützen die internationale anti es
koalition durch luftbetankung durch
lufttransport und aufklärung wir beraten
aber auch die irakischen
sicherheitskräfte vor ort und als freie
demokraten was uns besonders wichtig bei
der letzten mandatsverlängerung im
herbst 2020 einen entschließungsantrag
einzubringen und dessen wichtigste
punkte sind auch jetzt endlich umgesetzt
worden wir stellen sicher dass wir keine
pmf angehörigen mehr ausbilden wir haben
einen klaren fokus jetzt auf die zivil
militärische zusammenarbeit und den
vernetzten ansatz außerdem wollen wir
eine bündnis zusammenarbeit und keine
bilateralen abmachungen und ganz wichtig
endlich haben wir auch die auswertung
die evaluierung des einsatzes und das
ist wirklich etwas neues und uns sehr
wichtig
wir haben als regierungskoalition
miteinander vereinbart unsere
auslandseinsätze regelmäßig und
systematisch zu evaluieren und das wird
auch für diesen einsatz gelten wir
wollen die erfahrungen aus dem einsatz
auswerten und wir wollen wissen was gut
funktioniert ist wo und wie erreichen
wir unsere ziele und wo erreichen wir
sie nicht und das wollen wir im
vernetzten ansatz auswerten und das
heißt auch diplomatische erfolge gehören
dazu dazu gehören auch fortschritte der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit das müssen
wir bewerten und dabei dürfen wir nie
vergessen dass sicherheit und stabilität
die voraussetzung überhaupt erstmal für
entwicklungshilfe ist das heißt wer
schulen brunnen bauen will der
krankenhäuser und landwirtschaft dort
auf errichten will der muss zuallererst
mal für sicherheit und stabilität sorgen
entscheidend sind also nicht
militärische erfolge entscheidend ist ob
wir den menschen im irak mehr frieden
mehr stabilität und hoffnung auf eine
bessere zukunft bringen können das daran
müssen sich unsere 1er zu messen und das
ist auch das ziel dieses mandats ich
danke allen unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten die an dieser vision
mitarbeiten und werbe auch bei ihnen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen um
zustimmung vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege müller
nächste rednerin in dieser debatte ist
sie wie dagdelen sie ist mitglied im
auswärtigen ausschuss für die
linksfraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die verlängerung des bundeswehr
einsatzes im irak durch die
bundesregierung zeigt deutlich
eigentlich die doppelbödigkeit deutscher
außenpolitik insbesondere der grünen und
da helfen auch die ganzen kuriosen
rechtfertigung nicht man sei da nicht
umgefallen denn natürlich sind sie hier
umgefallen und schneller als manch einer
gedacht hätte in der opposition haben
sie diesen einsatz noch abgelehnt die
situation vor ort sei
unverantwortlich viel zu gefährlich das
mandat rechtswidrig und ohne
völkerrechtliche grundlage und das ist
jetzt alles anders das ist lächerlich
meine damen und herren
tagtäglich gibt es bei paketen angriffe
auf ausländische militärbasen im irak
und deshalb ist es skandalös dass sie
das leben deutscher soldaten derart
leichtfertig aufs spiel setzen was gibt
was die völkerrechtliche argumentation
angeht ist schon bemerkenswert wie
heruntergekommen hier ihre standards
jetzt sind ihnen reicht jetzt die
einladung einer geschäftsführenden
regierung im irak auf abruf ohne
parlamentarische mehrheit als
völkerrechtliche legitimation die auch
noch gegen den ausdrücklichen beschluss
des irakischen parlaments handelt
ausdrücklicher beschluss des irakischen
parlaments von dem sie noch letztes jahr
lobenswert berichtet haben das ist doch
grotesk meine damen und wer in der
position das eine sagt aber in der
regierung dann das gegenteil macht der
begeht nicht nur eine wählertäuschung
nein sondern beschädigt auch die
glaubwürdigkeit der politik insgesamt
und das gilt auch im hinblick auf julien
assange der journalist hat
kriegsverbrechen der us-armee im irak
öffentlich gemacht und soll dafür in den
usa lebendig begraben werden und sie
frau berbalk haben dies in der
opposition noch kritisiert und wenn es
ihnen tatsächlich um die menschen im
irak und die menschenrechte ginge würden
sie dieses schweigen zu julian assange
beenden das sind wir auch den
angehörigen der irakischen journalisten
schuldig die damals kaltblütig von einem
us apache hubschrauber heraus ermordet
wurden bis heute diese verbrechen
ungesühnt geblieben sind handeln sie
jetzt erheben sie ihre stimme für die
freiheit von julian assange
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau kollegin dagdelen und
als letzter redner in dieser debatte
folgt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der kollege doktor
einheit brande
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen die wir grünen fraktionen
liebe außenministerin herzlich
willkommen in der realität
über jahre hinweg haben sie von diesem
pult aus wohl fall begründet warum der
einsatz der bundeswehr im irak schlicht
unverantwortlich ist zitat annalena
baerbock und haben letzte im jahr 2020
noch einen antrag gestellt die
bundeswehr sofort aus dem irak
abzuziehen heute haben sie zum teil gut
begründet warum es sinnvoll ist dass wir
als land auch weiterhin einen beitrag
zur stabilisierung des iraks mit
leistungs- und auch mit bundeswehr
weiter in dem land bleiben das begrüße
ich ausdrücklich
aber meine verehrten damen ministerin
was ihnen heute auch gelungen ist sie
haben es geschafft innerhalb von 30
minuten
die scheinheiligkeit der außen und
sicherheitspolitik
der ampel vor aller welt vorzuführen die
entscheidende
[Applaus]
die herr trittin vielen dank für den
hinweis ich weiß aber von mich und
möchte mich mit einer frage lent nicht
gemein machen
aber was sie gemacht haben sie haben ja
als entscheidende änderung des mandats
begründet dass syrien nicht mehr teil
des einsatzgebietes ist im mandatstext
selber haben sie aber natürlich
beschrieben dass die bedrohung durch den
es nicht begrenztes auf den irak sondern
dass es irak und syrien und die ganze
region betrifft und sie wissen auch
selbst dass dort die grenzen fließend
sind und das natürlich wenn alle so
handeln würden nämlich nur auf
bestimmten bereit zu konzentrieren ganz
einfach ausweichräume mit entstehen sie
haben das mandat geändert nicht aufgrund
der lage vor ort sondern aufgrund der
lage hier oben nämlich im grünen
fraktions raum aber wissen sie was ist
jetzt bedeutet die bundeswehr ist jeden
tag mit a400m zur betankung flügen
unterwegs ich zitiere aus den letzten
dps vom im jahr 2021 bis einschließlich
13 zwölfter
625 einsatz flugs flüge mit knapp 2700
flugstunden und 2007
2740 luftbetankung vorgänger was
bedeutet das jetzt praktisch die
bundeswehr soldaten liegen die
betankungsflugzeuge die amerikanischen
und französischen jets fliegen die
einsätze die bundesministerin der
verteidigung hat sich dafür heute
explizit bedankt das heißt die fliegen
in syrien einsatz um aber zu tanken
müssen sie in den luftraum des iraks
oder nach jordanien zurück und das ist
doch ihre außenpolitik sie sind froh
dass andere diesen einsatz machen worten
aber selbst lieber vor der tür um sich
ja nicht in irgendeiner form die finger
schmutzig und das ist die
scheinheiligkeit
ich gehe ich verurteile und es ist auch
peinlich für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten
und ich würde sie bitten bei einer
zukünftigen erneuerung des mandats auch
syrien wieder mit in den operationsraum
zu nehmen das ist sinnvoll und damit
wird auch unser beitrag vor ort deutlich
glaubwürdiger herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege ich schließe
die aussprache interagieren und das war
dann hier die aussprache zum
bundeswehreinsatz im irak der antrag der
bundesregierung auf verlängerung
fortsetzung des einsatzes der wird nun
an die entsprechenden ausschüsse
übertragen federführend ist der
auswärtige ausschuss am 28 januar wird
dann im plenum darüber wieder diskutiert
und auch namentlich abgestimmt denn wir
haben ja die bundeswehr ist ja eine
parlamentsarmee das heißt der bundestag
muss jedem einsatz zustimmen bevor die
soldaten dann auch ins mandate ziehen
können das war die sitzungswoche in
dieser woche in mit der ersten
regierungsbefragung vom bundeskanzler
olaf scholz und dann grundsätzlichen
debatten zur politik der einzelnen
ministerien in zwei wochen sind wir hier
wieder im bundestag da geht es dann
unter anderem auch um die deutsche b 7
präsidentschaft die am ersten januar
2022 begonnen hat auch dann übertragen
wir natürlich hier wieder aus dem
plenarsaal
jetzt gebe ich erst mal ab zu meiner
kollegin ines arland im studio